[Music]
[Music]
I'm doc just the I'm doctor I can't walk
it annoys me
yeah those battles usually start with
either stunt team or the VFX team yes
sir
we owe it to Sam Parker to create these
amazing starts for Titan
got a ring full of movie stars got three
franchise carrying actors here this is
our first day here we are in Pinewood in
Atlanta and it's it's actually pretty
unbelievable you can actually engage in
this collaborative creative conversation
about what should this look like we
would show them our previous material
just to let them know like these are
there certain things that you would be
working with to get to this final
product it's gonna look awesome
when Chris doesn't
every character every hero involved has
to use the highest level of their power
just is just to stand a battlefield with
him the big to Thanos for his Iron Man
big showdown this has got all about some
cool movies leading up to him right here
I got a rapid interview here Josh Brolin
going hand to hand right here Stark how
do you know my name I know your soul it
is much like mine cursed with knowledge
my only curse is you one of my favorite
moments when próxima tells Scarlett wits
he'll die alone as will you she's not
alone in a real real moment of threat
there's two other women they're starting
by each other it's really great to see
that the audiences are embracing really
strong female super heroines that is one
of the biggest cheer moments in the film
I know you have found something my sense
of peace okay now you are going to
father
I told you to go
we need to destroy your Buffalo how long
do I start around correcting for oh yeah
you're up good
oh my god he's gonna be the better
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious these
conviction this is the only solution
he's seen it firsthand on his planet
Titan was like most planets he only
faced extinction on also the solution
genocide what I predict kingdoms
congratulations you're a prophet under
survivor
Tony knows just by the way that Bruce
Banner describes Thanos it's a different
game now
low-key detect on New York
that's him he is the biggest army in the
universe and he is not gonna stop just a
shear force is something that none of
the Avengers has ever encountered before
[Music]
darkness has been inside my head for six
years so I say we take the fight to him
heroes are only as good as their villain
but the Avengers were built for anything
that's for stopping Santos from
completing his goal
[Music]
on really isn't something one considers
for balancing the universe but this does
put a smile on my face Bombay the way
their Rousseau's work they're willing to
try different things it was a lot of
input and we could we could share how we
would express ourselves what war cries
we use this what condoms we have another
one that's more okay what's that one
it's my father
yeah means Windham yes are you probably
and separate them and they just go ah
you get the actors involved and of
course they know their characters better
than anybody
they have great input it's the greatest
what kind of forever you've ever said
this could be it you know it became with
like sort of the cadence of the whole
set people walking around saying what
kind of flow
so when Thanos shows up we really wanted
to make this the most powerful moment
ever eyes up
stay sharp the movie sort of keeps
twisting at the end there in ways that
you can't believe that it's going one
step beyond and that the the fate of our
characters and the fate of the universe
are still at play in terms of our
choices about who Fanus would end up
eradicating with his snap you know it's
very story focus how do we pay off each
individual character storyline most most
profoundly Steve the first person to go
is Bucky Barnes and it's shot from
Captain America's perspective you know
we're watching cap go through the
experience of watching him go away we're
watching a Koi a who's number one
mission it is in life is to protect the
king she watches the King go in front of
her and to see those characters react in
those situations is very powerful and
and resonant crude no oh god this is it
it's always leave Eunice
bringing Avengers infinity war to
audiences is an incredible road Joan I
have traveled with Marvel will be doing
these big wide shots and we're gonna
expand your tribe it's been a marathon
it's actually been a double marathon
because we shot both Avengers three and
four back-to-back in a one year time
frame so it's about as Herculean a
tasket because there is in filmmaking
the last thing that you guys were
playing was really good it's a distress
signal Rock if someone could be dying
but it has been I think the most
fulfilling creative endeavor we've ever
experienced we walked for 10 feet
straight on the streets of camera
there's been a teen films building up to
this and we wanted the audience to go on
a journey and have an emotional
catharsis in a response to the
situations that these characters get put
in and ultimately the choices that they
make which are heartbreaking
Joe and I we've counted ourselves as
fans long long before we ever became
filmmakers in the MCU these movies would
be nothing without the passion that the
fans bring to them we feel there's a
really special kinship with the fandom
and it drives us to ever greater heights
and storytelling
[Music]
Gus Brolin is bringing a new iconic
villain to life
Thanos is a very complex character what
he's doing from his point of view is a
very positive thing
he's basically an eco-terrorist and he
wants to eliminate 50% of the universe
to save the other 50%
[Music]
we wanted to tell a story about a
character with a really complex and
empathetic interior life there's not a
lot of actors that can give you both of
those things
Josh Bowman brings a reality to the
character he is wearing that mocap suit
he's wearing the motion capture cameras
the performance is coming through not
only in his gestures in his face but in
his eyes there's about 2,900 visual
effects shots in the movie we wanted to
make it as photographic as possible and
I think that that's the most important
part
[Music]
it's been a decade of signs and wonders
ten years it's pretty extraordinary it
is just the most remarkable achievement
it's a very conscious act to go and make
a motion picture let alone think about
launching and sustaining a cinematic
universe I mean nobody had even heard of
that five or six years ago
I'm Peter violently dr. strange all use
made-up names pretty doll since I see
this yeah collective isn't it I mean
just a bit part of it you can't fit any
more people on that poster and everyone
deserves to be there you know and
everyone has fought for their place in
the MCU it's such an amazingly humble
group of people and everyone's easy to
work with there are team players
surprise this will be such fun I love
all these actors they've made it so fun
it's it's like a big family really we're
all having fun and we're really allowed
to be the best versions of whatever
these giant movies are
you're given a set of circumstances in
the script and you go try to put your
secret sauce on that and make it fun and
entertaining and I think what's
extraordinary is how that baton has been
passed in such a magnanimous way from
all these franchises now bring them all
together it's just so epic are you
yawning to have created these different
worlds and made them so sort of full and
rich and then bring them all together
for these last two movies it's so like
it's really been ten years in the making
is a very very unique film I'm glad it's
worked out this way because we had been
working our asses off for a while to
have come this far 19 movies 10 years
and still be going and still have people
lining it and still be doing something
that's new and profound and culturally
significant that's a dream come true
[Music]
everybody stay where you are I'm gonna
ask one time who are you where the
avenger give Santos
if he gets all the Infinity stones
he'll wipe out half the universe
everything you know everything you love
it will all be gone just like that well
he's never Ford me yeah he has he's
never fought me twice getting new hammer
better be some hammer he's coming to us
I say we take the fight to him
you guys are screwed now
[Applause]
[Music]
oh by the way this is a friend of mine
tree hi hi I'm Steve Rogers
together we can stop France
[Music]
where's your guy
[Music]
dude you're embarrassing me from the
Wizards
[Music]